well we've got a very special guest with
us Jennifer that's right we have 13
world champion garry kasparov humans
rights activist walker and of course the
brain behind the Grantchester
from sunny Croatia Italy Croatia it's
it's it's already nine nine quarter past
9 p.m. so it's not that sunny but so the
temperature today was nearly just it's
over over hungry
so what are your impressions so far of
the st. Louis rabbit and blitz this is
the again I made blunders two years ago
okay I could justify it by being old and
rusty but these guys are making wonders
that that you know it's even I'm getting
confused just now I think it's the only
one explanation
they are just they're overworked because
it's hard right because there's so many
so many blunders look look at mvl in
bliss we never report MBL's the set
around today it's black and just
technically winning position I mean any
move neither foreigners he plays G 500
days before spending one second and it's
just instead of winning is lost and and
now obviously want to ask me about
matters my answers I don't know do you
okay explain that man was losing four
games and Rockets know which one it is
the style it has it's not losing games I
mean that's the game was Aronian it's
just in since I think he could figure to
finish it or blindfold I mean it's
technically winning position you need
the castle up like we need to quit me
three just hit stay he doesn't need time
yet fifteen minutes on his clock and
then Bishop is an ice age for okay
mystical before yes I could have missed
that Iran today maybe two years ago but
twenty five years ago
I doubt so it's the yeah my only
explanation is I think the guy's just a
plate too much but somehow this is they
they lose this sentence in just in their
fingers because something is dead wrong
you you can't have so many mistakes that
I look typical it's just they're great
explosive bullets on rocket yeah a Gary
Magnus had a month off a month the kids
said he was tired yeah but look still
you know how many told us he played this
year exactly yeah you stopped count
alternates it's not just in it and also
again which Magnus is just probably see
now we have two separate manuals from
the rest of the field because Magnus
says justice could be another story it's
just you it's like a debacle sort you
know he plays every tournament it'll be
expecting to win and trust me
you know I wasn't this situation is it's
it's it's hell the pressure on you yes
it's and one day you know things could
go wrong and then you get like one
mistake is followed by another you face
yeah all I wanted to ask you you
famously said that the Teth world's a
better place when Levon Aronian is
playing well what do you make of his
performance here so far look he's
probably the most stable player I
wouldn't say it was impressed because he
had a pretty bad end game we can send VL
in the first round in rapid so he was
lost against Magnus but you know it's
it's it's this tournament is not about
being creative it's about being steady
and definitely what is stating services
he's he's not making as many blunders as
others do so and that's why he's on top
and again it's good good news so you
know he's you know stamina if he can you
know keep up with this pace and which is
this quality of not making blunders and
it's playing solid games so you can win
toward convincingly and you know
probably probably will secure his I
don't know I'm not sure it was a
security spot you know for London final
but it seems to me that except Magnus
but nobody can be sure anymore even the
DL after booting Paris so you say that
you think there's a lot of blunders in
that part of the reason is because the
players are so tired because the chest
calendar
is so crowded but isn't that also a good
thing that so many people want to host
phenomenal chess tournaments what's your
solution I don't know a solution so I'm
just you know I feel sorry about my my
forum colleagues because Genesis you
know seeing they're making blunders and
looking at internet you know sync
lalalala you know from from bunch of
amateurs you know that's makes me feel
sick people are celebrating when mvl or
Mac was making brother I don't like you
you came up with a grand Chester you
must have some solution fix it for a
scary look but it's just no it's okay
it's the solution cannot be found just
within branches to the solution can be
in a complex but we are dealing with
crazy fede calendar I mean they just
these these guys are just coming at the
last Matthew's for extra comments so
when we when we extended granted story
from here I think you know eight vents
instead of you know five or six so we
looked at the calendar and was empty
empty but he had many many many holes
that we could feel yeah because there's
no chess olympiad
so we said okay why not why not exceed
extending branches tool because as you
said great need more people would like
to do two hostage we could go to Africa
would go to India's main but all of a
sudden you know we just you know we have
to deal with feeder you know it's
stalling for for quality qualification
to almonds into the into the calendar
and that's not you can expect all the
players to refuse
feed the qualifiers because they don't
have the chance fair chance to qualify
but it means you know they have to play
almost you know every week exactly so
maybe we just have to have the people
online watching a game stop writing long
could see that evaluation jumps you know
- for two-plus look you know if we treat
it as an entertainment that's good news
and I don't know we never cumulation the
player because you know they I think
some of them are thinking about my dad
now I just plum then everybody's
laughing at me Internet you should
probably ask Maurice you should ask them
you know what do they think about Gary
haters are gonna hate and those people
who are laughing could not hold a candle
to the host great players I don't think
we can work that no way in the world
like you know I just I I'm you know I'm
you know I'm nostalgic about times when
I played we could make a blunder nobody
dare to criticize us I still think what
we know today
you know after Abidjan after zagreb
after paris and now you know is in
Louie's branches too is a great success
it's just it's intentionally off from
the entire world and again if we can fix
the calendar and make your place a
little bit of rest between tournaments
you know it will it will go on it'll
continue and of course then Lewis you
know it's approved again it's a it's a
capital of the chest wall area about
what you were saying about the players
being tired I noticed in Croatia during
the classical Grantchester event that
you only had one free day 11 games in
one free day you talk about exhausting
the players there were some exhausted
players in Croatian we're gonna have the
same in the same field cup
I have only one free day how come we
couldn't have allowed for a second free
day in there are two reasons one of
course is the cost of the event you know
that's the you have to respect local
organizers but another one every day
counts
so Zachary was so close so let's the
it's two to two to the next Phebe event
so yes I couldn't agree more minutes I
would if I had you know if I if I had my
say and we could have a calendar in a
fixed you know without any for alien
interference so I would definitely add
at least one one extra day for for for
for classic maybe even to just you know
to make sure that they have rest and
they just you know they can come back
you know fresh and just you know hungry
for a good fight exactly so it was just
that the Riga Grand Prix
interfered there yeah okay is this all
grand pretty now I just I remember when
in the beginning of this year we we got
a call from Venus and excuse me guys
that now we have to reschedule your
events because we have for four extra
tournaments to add and and then just and
then we had to start pushing things
around so the the the game is not to
start by carrying who do you think is
going to surprise us and make the final
four to London obviously Magnus
extremely likely to get in
are there any dark horse pics that you
have for one of those for us I think
feel one spot so again the last last you
know critical moment but it seems to me
that he's no he's quiet now in peace he
plays steady chest I mean if MVL comes
back to his bliss he should do well in
this tournament and we'll offer him a
chance
and I think that's the it's the rest is
just there it's a grab and it just it's
the look classical offers offers big
opportunity and I would I would look at
marijuana as you know as you know it's
my B's chance to grab this fall so is
four months and in rabbit and blitz is
yet to be yet to be brooked carry and we
want to thank you so much for joining us
get back to enjoying enjoying the lovely
weather and the games is we're about to
start our next round
thank you my friend two weeks time yes
thanks Gary wonderful to have his
thoughts on the grand Chester and while
he might not be pleased with the number
of mistakes
the fans are certainly entertained by
this incredible series of events with
almost two million in prize fund